hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure Meinung
und willkommen zu einem neuen Video
heute gibt es den großen Proteinshake
Test ich mache ja seit längerer Zeit
jetzt Sport und was gehört zum Sport
dazu natürlich broteine
[Musik]
ich kenne mich in dem Thema noch nicht
ganz so aus ich habe jetzt hier ISM ab
und zu mal schon getrunken aber ich weiß
ja gar nicht was die Welt der
Proteinshake noch so bietet vielleicht
schmeckt einer noch viel besser oder hat
viel bessere Werte dafür haben wir uns
ganz lange vorbereitet ich habe echt
viele Infos und versuche das heute mit
euch zu lernen und falls ihr Profis seid
in dem Gebiet tschuldigung falls sie
irgendwas sage was ihr nicht so seht
oder irgendwas nicht weiß alle
Besserwisser jetzt aufgepasst schreibt
einfach in die Kommentare euer Wissen
ist gut und wichtig und bevor ich jetzt
noch 300 Mal
oder die m sage dieses Video ist nicht
gesponsert und jetzt alle zusammen
dieses Video ist nicht gesponsert
also warum braucht der Körper Protein na
ja das ist einerseits zum Muskelaufbau
und andererseits einfach so zum Leben ne
das ist ein wichtiger Baustein einfach
für uns wie viel Protein braucht denn
ein Mensch 0,8 bis 1 Gramm pro Kilogramm
Körpergewicht wenn du Leistungssportler
bist ändert sich das
zwei Gramm pro Kilo Körpergewicht wir
werden heute fast ausschließlich vegane
Proteinshakes testen das liegt daran
dass mein Körper bei Laktose sagt nein
nein das kommt hier nicht rein das am
meisten verbreiteste protein was man
kennt ist
Laktose wenn man keine Probleme mit
Laktose hat dann ist es auch sehr gut
verdaulich und wird vom Körper schnell
verwertet dann gibt's so ein Protein was
Kasein heißt noch ein bisschen tiefer
ein Thema drin es ist in Milch und Käse
drin
z.B gut für über die Nacht wir
beschäftigen uns heute aber mit
pflanzlichen Protein da gibt's noch mal
den Unterschied zu mehr Komponenten
Protein oder dann einfachen Protein also
ob es aus ein oder zwei verschiedenen
Protein besteht oder sogar aus drei dann
spricht man von mehr Komponenten Protein
aber Kinder das ist schon so weit im
Thema das lassen wir das verstehe ich
selber nicht wir beginnen unsere Reise
mit Alpha foods vegan Protein ich habe
immer Versuch Vanille zu kriegen ich
habe in zwei nicht Vanille bekommen und
dann ist etwas anderes damit man so
wirklich den Geschmack miteinander
vergleichen kann
eine Portion
7 das Problem dass sie nur 15 Gramm
Proportion empfehlen wo andere 30 Grad
empfehlen und deswegen hat es auch nur
11 Gramm Protein pro Portion und
deswegen ist der Preis für die Portion
auch nicht so ganz echt wenn es nur ums
Protein geht und ich werde jetzt nicht
immer die volle Portion anmischen weil
sonst habe ich hier drei Liter Shake und
das ist Timo
es riecht wie Keks zeigt aber nicht
gebacken ist der Löffel immer so drin
versteckt der Geruch ist gut
eine halbe Portion machen
[Musik]
tschüss
Packung empfohlen wird und hier steht
Wasser
[Musik]
trinkbare Gefühl
Punkt es kostet dann dafür dass man halt
eine doppelte Portion nehmen müsste ganz
schön viel mit Neuerungen
weil ihr mir auf Instagram geschrieben
habt welche E-Mail
war auf jeden Fall oft damals gefunden
da haben natürlich auch verschiedene
Arten das kann man zu Fuß bringen noch
sagen ein bisschen teuer eine Portion
kostet 1 € 19 das hier ist natürlich
wieder Komponenten Protein und anders
als einfach food hat das kein Soja sie
auch mal ganz gut finde weil so ja
vertrage ich nicht so gut Mogelpackung
empfehlen könnt schreibt
riechen tut es mehr nach Proteinpulver
als es andere
hier spülen
Geschmack irgendwas kommt da noch mit
euch
die da so drin sind also da sind in
jedem eigentlich noch andere Stoffe drin
vier von zehn wäre nicht zu fies sein
mit der Geschmack
Cookie do
ugh ansonsten ja Süßungsmittel wie bei
allen hier sind wir bei 90 Cent pro
Portion dabei wir haben jetzt aber hier
die Probe bestellt die kostet um die 250
was natürlich praktisch ist wenn man
sich erstmal durchprobieren möchte aber
wenn man dann die große Packung kauft
dann wird es natürlich günstiger ne ja
und das müssen wir uns jetzt mal
anschauen
Rocker zu sagen Hocker ist von
irgendeinem Influenza produziert ne ja
ja
eine Person des öffentlichen Lebens
ich bin ja bei Rockern der auch noch mal
über die Verpackung zu sprechen ist
immer sehr ansprechend gemacht
aber hier hast du nicht diesen komischen
Geschmack der sich auf die Zunge legt
das ist lecker bekommt von mir 7,5 von
10 laut unseren Recherchen ist das hier
schon unser heimlicher Favorit das ist
Puddingpulver von DM also Preis da
liegen wir bei 64 Cent pro Portion mit
24 Gramm Protein pro Portion liegt der
ganz weit vorne
mit Löffel
Farbe
Version empfohlen hat deswegen
[Musik]
der Wand kleben
ist so schlimm
also
haben die denn sonst noch künstlichen
Zucker nur Datteln
und keine künstlichen Süßstoffe pro
Portion trinkt man hier 13 Gramm Zucker
es ist dattelzucker aber es ist Zucker
und wir haben mal ausnahmsweise kein
Plastikdeckel
Proportion irgendwie hier bei 1,9 €
das macht natürlich den Geschmack immer
noch mal ein bisschen besser
lecki
besser schmecken
eo
also
max
ist dieser Geschmack ja als ob man sein
Altpapier eingeweicht
hättest
auch also eins von zehn ist meine
Bewertung
von Rewe
i am 72 Cent time Soja mit 17,7 Gramm
hat es ein bisschen weniger Protein als
seine Kollegen
[Musik]
Geschmack der sich auf die Zunge legt
also was sollen wir sagen vom Design
haben sie ein bisschen versucht hier
einfach gut zu sein hier unten ansonsten
finde ich vom Design ein bisschen
altbacken also mit dieser Holzoptik und
so geschmacklich ist das einfach nichts
also es erinnert mich nicht an Vanille
das Schmecken ja so Rocker daneben die
schmecken ja einfach grandios ja
schlecht zwei drei vier von zehn
[Musik]
was in deinem Körper Laktose verarbeitet
[Applaus]
test test
ja mein Gott ist das lecker im Gegensatz
zu den Anderen
schmeckt auf jeden Fall dass es mit
Milch ist also schmeckt sehr gar nicht
milchshakig
extrem gut durch also man trinkt es und
merkt sofort ah Vanille oh sehr viel
Fett 4,6
geschrieben
möchte und dabei ein richtig leckeren
Shake haben will absolute Empfehlung
haben wir gleich den nächsten dieses
kleine Tetrapack ist von Annick und ja
und ist der vegan pflanzlich ohne
Zuckerzusatz der Preis ist 2,49 € pro
Portion da sind wir 30 Cent günstiger
als mit den Babels fertig gesagt und die
Menge ist sie gleich keine Milch oder so
gut gemeint ne die haben das wirklich
gut gemeint mit den Gewürzen ich glaube
daran es schmeckt sehr intensiv nach
Kurkuma nach Pfeffer nach Zimt nach
nicht so sehr Vanille also hier hat man
einen sehr nachhaltiges Produkt die
Kappe ist pflanzenbasiert du hast einen
Tetrapack das ist ja irgendwie auch gut
aber ich habe keine Ahnung was welches
Thema weil ich will dass das Produkt gut
ist aber sie hat halt
[Musik]
für eine Probepackung bezahlt man 250
und da kann man sich dann erstmal durch
Testen ist aber auch ganz ehrlich gut
bevor man sich so riesen Pakete
irgendwie in kiloiden Pulver holt und
das dann nicht machen wegschmeißt dann
lieber ein bisschen Geld investieren und
sich durchprobieren
ich habe Nuss Nougat Praline weil es
Vanille nicht gab es riecht
ach so lecker ich habe irgendwie das
Gefühl dass es jetzt hier ein richtiger
Banger wird den Gramm
ja es riecht super
so sollte es schmecken ich habe so ein
ganz komischen kleinen Nachgeschmack das
könnte aber daran liegen dass ich schon
eine Million Proteinshakes probiert habe
aber erster Eindruck
keine Ahnung
also 9 von 10 ne habt uns echt nicht
enttäuscht und preislich sind sie nicht
besonders teuer nicht besonders günstig
unser
letztes
Richtung Milky chocolate da gab es jetzt
auch keine Vanille und ich konnte nicht
warten das auszuprobieren ich bin
Cappuccino Pulver super vielleicht
erklärt der Preis den Geschmack 1,15 €
pro Portion aber auch das meiste Protein
24,6 Gramm mischen wir uns mal eine ganz
kleine Portion hier an das hohe Protein
erklärt sich durch die Portionsgröße 35g
pro Portion deswegen ist da halt dann
auch mehr proport
Dehnübungen
ja sieht nur am Schnee
oder Essl ich glaube ESM für dich
und Babels sehr zu empfehlen
weil sie alle ähnlich gut schmecken an
die schmeckt z.B morgens besser mir
schmeckt ESM besser daran merkt man aber
dass der Geschmack ja auch individuell
ist und man so ein bisschen für sich
selber gucken muss was am besten
schmeckt und von den proteinwerten sind
sie alle ähnlich hoch und deswegen sind
sie wirklich gut zu empfehlen mit seiner
Portionsgröße da hat man nämlich 35g
hier nur 25
wichtig ob ihr Süßungsmittel überhaupt
zu euch nehmen wollt also es ist ja ein
bisschen umstritten wie schädlich oder
gesund und Süßungsmittel ist eine
geringe Menge am Tag ist ja noch okay
aber man sollte glaube ich auch wirklich
drauf achten nicht den ganzen Tag
proteinriegelproteinshakes irgendwelche
Süßigkeiten mit Zucker Alternativen
aber wir schließen hier natürlich
niemanden aus ne ihr wart alle ganz toll
es ist am Ende Geschmackssache ob euch
das schmeckt außerdem
mal wieder zu einem weiteren Video mal
gucken was es sein wird ich bin mir
gerade nicht ganz sicher bis dann danke
Ali für die Recherche